so last night we had our twitter storm
we shouted at the top of our lungs to
amazon that we want stargate back
but how effective was it
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv
movie channel
[Music]
so i'm going to be the first one to
admit that i don't really understand
twitter that is one of those reasons why
matt came on board with us so that he
could guide me in this area he is far
more technically minded than me and he
really does help me out on everything
computer based
so i've spoken to matt and he's told me
that we had over a hundred thousand
retweets of the we want stargate hashtag
and you know that is not a bad start at
all i have also seen several sources
have told me that we were trending on
twitter last night and that that is
actually quite a big deal so
we were trending a couple of weeks ago
we were trending again and i can tell
you from very simple experience that
looking at my twitter feed it is full of
stargate i'm getting 30 40 notifications
an hour at the moment still of constant
retweets and likes and everything else
from all the tweets that i've sent out
so
on the surface it looks like it's pretty
successful we wanted to get it trending
and we did
but as you know if you're a regular site
tracker i have a few sources that i
speak to that are in and around amazon
and mgm so i put the message out
does anybody know if this is actually
being listened to and i had a couple of
responses now i talked to a couple of
different people that work in different
backgrounds some of them are just you
know normal run-of-the-mill people that
happen to work at an mgm building or
amazon a couple of them are creative
types and you know a few people who work
with contracts and things like this they
work in various fields is what i'm
trying to tell you
two of people that i do speak to both
came back to me and said that they know
that on a weekly basis
amazon do sort of like um look at social
media and they look at what the trends
are at the moment
they run reports that then get sent up
the ladder by the way if you do like the
content please don't forget to like and
subscribe and hit the bell notification
you can also consider becoming a member
hit the join button that little bit of
contribution every month really helps us
to create more content
there is a weekly report everything that
happened last night will have appeared
on those reports and those trends and
they will get booted up to amazon they
also explained to me though that they
then break this report down this social
media trending thing about into areas
that are relevant to amazon products so
i should say this is tv and video based
um according to them they do this from a
sort of a purchasing point of view as
well so they do it for both areas of the
amazon business so they don't just do it
for like what people are talking about
social media that's relevant to movies
tv etc they do it's also for what's
relevant to shopping trends they do it
to you know from the from the that
retail side of things
but from the tv and movie basis they
look at trends because they're trying to
figure out what the next big project's
going to be is horror coming back is
sci-fi how popular that is
should they look at doing a rom-com
because that's trending you know
whatever whatever the trends are that's
what they're looking for but they also
then break those products down into
things that are relevant to amazon so
things that they own now that's going to
be important obviously because mgm is
owned by amazon
so therefore amazon owns stargate so
when we have this twitter store and this
frenzy of comments and messages and
chats that is going to get noticed by
amazon now
it's going to take a couple of weeks for
a lot of this information to come
through and to bounce up to executives i
completely understand that
but the message i'm getting from the
people i speak to at amazon and mgm is
that not only will they have heard they
will have heard loudly because these
people care about metadata they care
about numbers on a spreadsheet and a
nice big spike on a graph is something
they will pay attention to
on the whole thing off i asked again
whether they think this is going to
happen and i am getting constant noise
from these people that stargate is 100
on the docket they are going to make a
stargate series
it's just how they make it is the
question they haven't decided how they
want to do it
whether brad wright gets to make his
script looks doubtful
whether brad wright will still be on the
show as a show runner is still up in the
air it's still very possible so it does
seem very unlikely that we're actually
going to get brad's script that he wrote
nearly three years ago for mgm get made
into a pilot but that could mean they
ask him to do a rewrite something that
is more in line with what they want to
produce um from the stargate franchise
or they might go with somebody
completely new
personally i think and this is just my
opinion they'll go a new trek style and
they'll do some sort of hybrid between
canon and something completely new
something that respects what came before
to a point
but there is still a new product new for
a new audience so that is where we're at
at the moment yes the twitter storm 100
will have been heard by amazon
let's just hope they also heard that we
want brad wright to be in charge
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
it really helps us out and if you like
the content please consider hitting the
join button and becoming a fully fledged
side tracker as always please guys stay
safe i'll see
[Music]
you